so in this problem they're telling us
that in outer space the distance an
object travels varies directly with the
amount of time that it travels and
that's of course assuming that it's not
accelerating and there's no net force
and all of that on it so i guess they're
talking about a specific object so some
specific object the amount the distance
that it travels is directly it varies
directly it varies directly with the
amount of time that it travels so if we
think of it in in terms of constants of
proportionality and direct variation we
could say that the distance
we could say that the distance is equal
to some constant times the time
times the time that it travels the
distance varies directly with the amount
of time that travels for this particular
object
if an asteroid travels three thousand
miles in if the asteroid travels three
thousand miles in six hours what is the
constant of variation so the distance is
three thousand so we have d is equal to
three thousand miles
we have three thousand miles is the
distance and that's going to be equal to
the constant of variation
the constant of variation times the time
times six hours
so if we want to solve for the constant
of variation we can just divide both
sides by 6 hours
6 hours
and we divide the right hand side by 6
hours
and so 3000 divided by 6 is 500
and 6 divided by 6 is 1. the hours also
cancel out if we care about the units
and so the constant of proportionality
the left-hand side is just 500
500 and then we have miles per hour
miles per hour
500 miles per hour and that is equal to
k so the constant proportionality is 500
miles per hour or you could say 500 if
you're not too worried about the units
or we should say the constant of
variation to use the terminology that
they actually use in the question